this might look like Virgin Atlantic's
newest super hip lighting scheme but
it's actually Boeing's prototype
self-cleaning bathroom that glow isn't
mood lighting
it's an ultraviolet light that can
happen 99.99% of germs your fellow
fliers leave behind when you close the
door behind you two sets of UV lights
will turn on and disinfect the whole
tiny room in just three seconds for
extra protection the faucet soap
dispenser hand dryer and toilet seat
we'll all be hands-free in between
flights airline crews will still
manually clean the lavatory since there
are some messes no amount of sunlight
can tackle if you're hoping to get
bronzed on your way to the Bahamas
though you're out of luck
bones UV rays aren't the kind you see in
tanning salons and they should only turn
on when the lab is unoccupied so maybe
your middle seat isn't going to get
bigger any time soon but at least your
time on that other seat should be a
little more pleasant